[موسيقى]
مسلحونا تابعون لمليشيات الحوثي ينتشرون
في كل مكان السلاح متوفر اما الطعام فلا
اليمنيون واليمنيات يتدورون جوعا حسب صور
انتشرت مؤخرا عبر الانترنت
واشارت لها جريده الشرق الاوسط في تحقيق
لها عن الوضع الماساوي في اليمن
المشهد يبكي كل من له قلب بينما الحوثيون
يعيشون رغد العيش
وبدرماتهم تعفنت من كثره الاموال المقدسه
وهم مستمرون بالمتجر بمعاناه الشعب اليمني
بكل قبح وخبث واجرام
كما ان الجماعه دابت على الاستحواذ على
المساعدات الغذائيه الاتيه من ميناء
الحديده حيث يتم تحويلها لاتباع الجماعه
وبالتالي لا تستفيد منها الفئات الاكثر
تضررا
الحوثيون اضافه الى فرضهم الاتاوات على
المواطنين بادروا بزياده الضرائب
والتعريفات الجمركيه على التجار اجراء
تسبب برفع اسعار المواد الاستهلاكيه في
بلد انقطعت فيه رواتب الموظفين الحكوميين
منذ سته اعوام في المناطق المسيطر عليها
من قبل الحوثيين
سعيا لمعالجه الاسماء يهدف برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه الى ايصال المساعدات الغذائيه
الى حوالي 13 مليون من اليمنيين هذا العام
ويعد معدل سوء تغذيه الاطفال في اليمن من
اعلى المعدلات في العالم حيث يحتاج
مليونان ومئه الف طفل دون سن الخامسه الى
العلاج من سوء التغذيه الحاد العربيه